um
i mean
keeping it with your homies like talk
about how the intro and your boy shiloh
being part of the album how that like
like kind of give people the background
on who shiloh is and yeah you know he's
got the interlude and the
intro yeah yeah so shallow that's my
brother like um we we from
and we're not blood but we always was
with each other since day one so we
always used to tell everybody was
brothers both like light skin or
whatever so um this is like my brother
and um
he was rapping as well like before i was
not before i was but at the same time
but he was popping before i was got you
and me seeing him like that close but he
was still like super heavy in the street
[ __ ] you know
and um
so me seeing him like glowing up in his
way just on some straight street buzz on
didn't have no manager then i was his
manager at one point in time you were
managing yeah yeah i was managing him
because i just knew like okay i know how
to upload [ __ ] to like a tunecore
i know how to monetize just the regular
basic [ __ ] small [ __ ] and so um
me seeing him go up that kind of
a lot of times it just takes you seeing
things especially up close to
understand that you can attain
the same sort of things even to a higher
level and um us growing up together um
him getting locked up for 25 24 years to
be exact for murder um that's something
that messed up with me psychologically
because i end up blowing up um
or getting on the scene more so the year
after he gets locked up so i'm like damn
if i was able to if i was at where i'm
at now he might be in a whole different
situation you know but um
that's why i thought it was very
important to to highlight where he's at
you know on the intro and in the loot as
well that's dope um i was just on the
phone with a matter of fact when i came
in here oh word yeah yeah oh that's dope
yeah so when he like yeah i mean how how
long is he gonna be is he got a while or
yeah he got 24 years [ __ ] but um we
working right now working with a bunch
of you got a team of lawyers and i'm
working with uh robert rooks from reform
and um a couple other guys to to really
put all the resources that we have now
and able to in order to get him out as
well as my dog mack his co-defendant who
got 30 years another one of my dogs so
this is um just just trying to utilize
this access to
of relationships i have to be able to
help especially so close to home